hi i'm evan carmichael and in today's
video i wanted to answer a question for
one of my readers mary
i really like this one so mary writes in
hi evan i enjoy your articles great
information and inspiration
however i don't understand how you
actually earn your income
i've never bought anything from you and
you don't seem to be selling anything in
your posts
what do you actually do for a living i
would appreciate a reply regards mary
so thanks for the question mary i have a
hard enough time explaining to
friends and people i meet what i do so
i'll do my best here in this video
how i started was i really like helping
entrepreneurs that's why i said on my
website
i started by profiling famous
entrepreneurs and lessons that you can
learn from them
because that's what i found
inspirational i found it really helpful
for me
and i wanted to share that with other
entrepreneurs i started doing these
videos because people had a lot of
questions and i thought other people
could benefit from
having some video content as well where
i answered it so it all started around
me
wanting to help entrepreneurs that was
really my passion and i really believe
if you follow what you're really
passionate about and you add
a ton of value and you're really helpful
then success will follow you
so for me how i make money with my site
now is mostly
advertising and sponsorship so if you
click on any of the
articles that i have on the site you'll
probably see an ad somewhere on the site
also we tend to partner up with
organizations who are trying to reach
the entrepreneur community and they
might sponsor a section of the website
but i try not to be too blatant about
that and it's not overwhelming and i
don't usually have
promos in a newsletter or most places on
the website
i experimented a lot with different
business models i looked at the
affiliate marketing model for a while
where
that's basically where you're selling
somebody else's product and i had a hard
time
getting the value out of that and
putting my name behind it
you know i could maybe make a lot of
money i could pitch somebody's prop and
say hey this is the greatest thing ever
you know mary i think you should buy
this product because it's fantastic
but if i haven't used it and i haven't
found benefit in it then
i don't want you buying some info
product and maybe i make a good
commission off of it but then
you find out that it's a junky product
and say oh that happens a douchebag for
recommending it and then you're never
going to come back and visit my website
and that's not the relationship that i
want to build so
i want to try to promote things that i
actually use
and enjoy and find value in so i
didn't have a lot of success with the
affiliate marketing model
um i did create my own business planning
product
so i had a hard time finding a good
business plan product so i started my
own
so it is one product that we do sell but
mostly my revenue comes from advertising
and sponsorship
and it all started from me not not
trying to
go out and make a lot of money doing
advertising and sponsorship but
trying to help entrepreneurs and answer
their questions and help them grow their
business and
follow my passions that's what i really
enjoy so i hope that helps answer the
question
if you enjoyed the video please give it
a thumbs up and i'd also love to hear
your thoughts and feedback
if you want to leave a comment below the
video and stay tuned for the next
episode
you